socialist politics triumph since Spain
incumbent Prime Minister Pedro Sanchez
says progressive politics won Spaniards
have sent a very clear and categorical
message to Europe and to the world that
it is possible to win against
reactionary authoritarian and repressive
politics with progressive proposals but
forming a ruling coalition won't be easy
one likely Ally is the anti-austerity
far left party podemos led by Pablo
Iglesias the election mobilized a huge
number of people over 75% of the
electorate including those who support
the far-right enter Vox an
anti-immigration anti-feminist party
it's the first time a far-right party
has gained seats in Spain's Parliament
since the days of General Franco this is
only the beginning we told you about our
goal to initiate the reconquest and
that's exactly what we have done this is
a reconquest with a voice of parliament
as of today we can now say loud and
clear to the entire country that Vox has
come to stay the country's mainstream
conservative party the People's Party
suffered big losses it was their worst
election to date Spanish politics like
elsewhere is becoming more polarized the
election was pitched by Prime Minister
Sanchez's socialists as a bid to stop
the far-right very happy because I
thought that the extreme right would win
a lot more
but Spain reacted to stop that so I'm
very very happy
the Socialists won but for the first
time since the end of the military
dictatorship the far-right are now part
of Spain's national politics let's go
straight to Madrid for the latest now
and EWS Lisa Louis good morning Lisa
this is a qualified victory worrying for
the Socialists isn't it
which parties will a prime minister
Sanchez now be reaching out to to form
some type of stable coalition well it's
going to be really tricky but he
actually has about two possibilities so
on the one hand he could team up with
the far left who need us podemos that
won't be enough for a majority though so
we will need to bring in many other
smaller parties like for example the
Catalan or the Basque independent party
in a separatist party the other
possibility would be to team up with a
market liberal ciudadanos and that would
give him the majority in parliament
coalition wise that would be easier when
it comes to the ideology though it's
going to be tricky this election
campaign was very much along ideological
lines and it's kind of difficult to see
how these two parties that were very
much fighting with each other about
economic programs but also mainly about
the Catalonian questions a question will
then come together and form a coalition
part okay now who's on the other side of
this ideological divide that you
mentioned is the far-right box party how
will they be influencing national
politics now that they take up seats in
parliament
well Vox has gotten into Parliament will
get into Parliament for the first time
since the end of the Franco dictatorship
40 years ago and they will have a voice
there they will not be able to block any
laws but they will be able to very much
influence the national debate as they
have during this election campaign and
that will probably leave the country
more divided than beforehand
okay another element leading to were
indicative of rather the erosion of the
political centre is the poor showing by
the country's conservatives
happened to the Conservative Party well
it was quite a disaster really they
plummeted they only left with very few
seeds to compare to what they had
beforehand at least now during the
election campaign they already moved
very much to the right trying to grab
some of the votes that might go to Vox
looks like
Theodore darkness the market Liberal
Party might be become the the Wright's
number one party in the near future at
least of this trend continues so there's
a lot of soul-searching to be done by
the People's Party the Catalan
independence movement has been
dominating Spanish politics for a while
now where does this election leave them
where are the Catalonian separatists at
this point well it really depends on
what the outcome of the coalition talks
will be obviously they have gained some
seats in parliament but that will not be
enough to make sure that there that the
government takes a softer stance if they
don't get into Parliament if psoe teams
up with soo da da knows it might be
really complicated for them if PSOE goes
down the Oneidas podemos and other party
in a smaller party rate that might
actually be good for them because then
there would be more of an open door to
some kind of conciliatory talks Lisa
thanks very much for that
from Madrid Lisa Lewis for us this
morning